bien en este vídeo quiero ver las
distintas formas de ver de una manera
visual a un número mixto así que qué te
parece si empezamos con un número mixto
y se me antoja a tomarme dos enteros dos
enteros y con estos dos enteros voy a
hablar de dos enteros uno
octavo un octavo de muy buena opción
pero se me antoje mejor ponerlo como un
cuarto dos enteros un cuarto es lo que
me voy a tomar y lo voy a representar
una manera visual justo aquí así que si
cada una de estas cajas con ocho
cuadritos representa una unidad entonces
dos enteros sería tomarme dos de estas
tiras déjame tomarme este sería uno de
ellos
este sería mi primer y entero completo
todo esto sería mi primer entero
completo pero me tengo que tomar dos
entonces me hace falta otro lo voy a
tomar todo este de aquí todo este de
aquí también va a ser mi segundo entero
completo todo esto de aquí es mi segundo
entero completo ok y después me tengo
que tomar un cuarto más un cuarto más
pero aquí tengo ocho cuadritos tengo un
entero dividido en ocho partes así que
qué te parece si a este entero mejor lo
dividimos en cuartos
así que voy a tomar un cuarto un cuarto
dos cuartos tres cuartos y bueno cuatro
cuartos cuatro cuartos porque es un
entero y de este entero me voy a tomar
solamente la primera cuarta parte es
decir de todo esto que tengo aquí
solamente me voy a tomar la primera
parte solamente voy a tomar esto que
tengo aquí entonces justo esta es la
representación visual de dos enteros o
un cuarto dejamos de llenar mejor esto
de dos enteros un cuarto y bueno qué te
parece si ahora a este número mixto lo
descomponemos en partes y para esto
déjame traer otro de estos para que lo
veamos de manera visual y vamos a ir
descomponiendo dos enteros un cuarto en
parte citas y qué te parece si para
empezar como un medio me voy a tomar un
medio ya esto le voy a sumar algo pero
un medio sería tomarme del primer entero
a la mitad entonces voy a dividirlo
entre 2 entre 2 son 4 cuadritos ok tengo
justo este justo este y bueno mi otro
mi otra mitad justo este y entonces un
medio sería solamente tomarme la mitad o
una parte de estas dos solamente me voy
a tomar esta primera parte aquí tengo un
medio pero bueno un medio no es lo mismo
que dos enteros un cuarto por lo tanto
tengo que sumarle algo más así que qué
te parece si a esto le sumamos y se me
antoja tres octavos tres octavos y se
van tocan totalmente de short a vos
porque ya lo tenemos dividido en octavos
así que tres octavos son solamente tres
cuadraditos voy a dibujar 12
3 ok falta bastante para llegar a dos
enteros un cuarto así que qué te parece
si a esto le sumó ocho octavos se me
antoja son más de ocho octavos que por
cierto recuerda que 8 sobre 8 es lo
mismo que un entero entonces voy a tomar
8 octavos 1
234 de estos aquí voy a la mitad 5 6 7 y
8 y si te das cuenta ocho octavos es
justo lo que pensábamos un entero
completo ok pero todavía me falta me
faltan algunos cuadritos así que qué te
parece si a esto le sumó un octavo a
esto le voy a sumar otro octavo más más
un octavo y esto pues es solamente un
cuadradito de estos ocho y me faltan
estos dos pedazos de aquí entonces qué
te parece si a esto le sumó para
finalizar a dos octavos dos octavos y
dos octavos es tomarme uno de estos
cuadraditos y otro de estos cuadraditos
y qué crees ya llegamos justo a dos
enteros el cuarto dos enteros un cuarto
lo podemos ver como un medio más tres
octavos más ocho octavos más un octavo
más dos octavos llegamos justo a donde
empezamos es decir a cumplir 2
y dos cuadraditos de estos ocho que
tengo aquí abajo ahora hay varias formas
si tú puedes vender la que tú quieras
para expresar dos enteros en cuarto
podrías tomarlos en cuartos en medios no
lo sé lo que sí quiero que veas es que
esta parte que tengo aquí que nosotros
dijimos que era un medio es exactamente
lo mismo que tomarnos cuatro octavos que
toman los cuatro octavos si te das
cuenta lo que hicimos fue tomar uno dos
tres cuatro de estos ocho cuadraditos y
por otra parte a esto le sumamos a
déjame cambiar de color le sumamos tres
octavos tres octavos y después le
sumamos un octavo que fue justo estoy
aquí y después le sumamos un octavo y si
te das cuenta un medio más tres octavos
más un octavo o dicho de otra manera si
nosotros lo vemos todo en octavos nos va
a quedar que cuatro octavos más tres
octavos más un octavo es exactamente lo
mismo que ocho octavos que es un entero
un entero más otro entero que nos
tomamos de esos ocho octavos mandos
enteros y después éste un cuarto lo
formamos con
octavos 14 es lo mismo que dos octavos y
ya está aquí tengo otra representación
de estos dos enteros un cuarto o también
podemos decir que descompusimos a este
número mixto dos enteros un cuarto en la
suma de varias fracciones hasta la
próxima